StSteven Guilbeault que l'on vot
plplutôt aujourd'hui se faire
asassermenté comme nouveau
miministre de l'environnement. l
esest avec nous. Bonsoir.
OnOn peut dire que vous êtes
vrvraiment préparés pour ce
trtravail. Vous avez toute votre
vivie travailler du militantisme
etet maintenant en action
popolitique. Est-ce que vous
crcroyez que vous allez faire
dadavantage évoluer ce dossier n
ététant ministres que toute vos
anannées à Équiterre?
- - Quand je me suis lancé en
popolitique, ce n'est pas parce
quque le militantisme était un
coconstat d'échec. On a besoin e
didiversité d'actions dans la
sosociété. On a besoin de
mimilitants, on a besoin de gens
dadans les entreprises qui veult
fafaire des changements.
OnOn a besoin aussi de gens dans
nonos gouvernements qui sont prs
àà prendre des décisions peut-
êêtre plus courageuses
ququ'auparavant, et s'elle se
chchoix que j'ai fait. Loin de i
l'l'idée de dire que ceux qui
mimilitent encore font une erre.
- - M. Trudeau vous nomment à
l'l'environnemenent, ce qu'il
n'n'avait pas fait la dernière
fofois. Est-ce que vous voyez ça
cocomme une conclusion de la
réréflexion qu'il est prêt à alr
plplus loin?
- - Il le dit lui-même
auaujourd'hui. Il faut regardera
nonomination mais celle de mon i
etet collègue Jonathan Wilkinson
auaux ressources naturelles, qui
esest un ministère important das
lala lutte aux changements
clclimatiques. C'est un ministèe
clclé dans le cadre de cette
lulutte. Jonathan et moi avons
trtravaillé de façon collaborate
dedepuis deux ans. Le mandat que
lele premier ministre nous donnà
totous les deux et aux autres
miministres du cabinet et de
popoursuivre cette collaboratio.
JeJe pense que ce sera très
poporteur pour la lutte.
- - Je le disais en entrée de ju
àà l'émission, M. Trudeau n'a ps
lele luxe du temps. Il a peut-êe
dedeux ou trois ans. Est-ce que
vovous sentez ce rapport au tems
ququi change, qu'il faut accélér
mamais aussi que les gens voient
unune différence? Et en paie le
prprix aussi, que chacun de noua
unun prix à payer dans cette lue
popour le climat.
- - Vous avait raison, nous
n'n'avons pas beaucoup de temps.
S'S'il y a une chose que nous
avavons entendue lors de la
dedernière élection, c'est qu'ue
grgrande partie de la population
cacanadienne, particulièrement
chchez les jeunes, nous demandee
fafaire plus vite en matière de
lulutte aux changements
clclimatiques. C'est vrai partot
auau pays. La nouvelle mairessee
CaCalgary, un de ses premiers
gegestes sera de déclarer
l'l'urgence climatique à Calgar.
CeCe qui pense que c'est juste u
QuQuébec ou sur la côte ouest qe
leles gens sont préoccupés par s
chchangements climatiques, ce
n'n'est pas le cas. Sur la
ququestion du prix à payer, il
fafaut regarder ça de façon
glglobale. Si nous ne faisons
ririen, le prix à payer de
l'l'inaction climatique est très
élélevé. On le voit avec les
cacatastrophes naturelles qui ot
frfrappé l'ensemble de la planèe
etet qui s'accélère. La beauté u
sysystème de tarification carboe
cacanadien et qu'on retourne
l'l'argent aux gens en fonctione
leleur consommation d'émissionse
gagaz à effet de serre. Après, s
gegens ont le choix de continueà
avavoir des comportements qui st
plplus polluants et payer le prx
ouou adopter des comportements
momoins polluants. À partir de e
momoment, ça devient
écéconomiquement bénéfique pour.
- - On ne peut pas éternellement
nene pas avoir une pression etet
avavoir un effort à faire.
IlIl y a une vedette
enenvironnementale en France qui
avavait démissionné. Est-ce que
vovous voyez en cours de route e
lele gouvernement n'est pas
sésérieux, est-ce que vous
dédémissionnez rien?
- - Je connais très bien ce
frfrançais. Est-ce qu'il était
totout seul pour faire avancer s
dodossiers? Depuis deux ans, je
trtravaillais maintenant la main
avavec le ministre de
l'l'environnement et les autres
miministres pour faire avancer s
chchangements climatiques.
PoPour le dernier cabinet de
MoMonsieur Trudeau, la
reresponsabilité de la lutte aux
chchangements climatiques était
cocommune à tout le monde. Ce
n'n'est pas juste une personne i
esessaie de faire avancer sa,
c'c'est un effort collectif.
- - Je vous fais entendre le
prpremier ministre de l'Alberta.
JAJASON KENNEY
prpremier ministre de l'Alberta
- - Si Monsieur Guilbault suit
leles politiques qu'il appuyait
enen tant que militant auparava,
çaça serait un désastre pour
l'l'économie canadienne.
J'J'espère, par contre,
ququ'il va démontrer une approce
coconstructive et raisonnable.
- - Serez-vous raisonnables aux
yeyeux du premier ministre de
l'l'Alberta?
- - Les politiques que je
dédéfendais en tant que militant
écécologistes sont les politiqus
quque mon gouvernement met de
l'l'avant : l'élimination des
cocombustibles fossiles, plus
d'd'investissement en transport
cocollectif, plus d'investissemt
enen électrification. Nous nous
sosommes engagés dans la dernièe
cacampagne à mettre un plafond r
leles émissions de gaz à effet e
seserre. Je serais très heureuxe
cocollaborer avec Monsieur Kenny
etet son gouvernement en matière
dede lutte en changements
clclimatiques.
- - On va suivre tout ça. Merci